Сегодня я хотел бы поговорить с вами о
шести ужасных типов людей, которые
разрушают вашу жизнь, портят её,
превращают в хаос и не только личную
жизнь, но особенно бизнес. Я сегодня
расскажу о шести типах людей, с которыми
я как можно быстрее стараюсь прокретить
общение и пытаюсь, чтобы в моей жизни
они не появлялись. Хотя, конечно же, в
моей жизни они периодически появляются,
но я стараюсь минимизировать общение с
такими людьми. Итак, какие же это люди,
которые превращают вашу жизнь в хаос,
которые разрушают вашу жизнь? И не
просто жизнь, разрушает и бизнес,
разрушают семью и вашу личную жизнь.
Итак, поехали. Рейтинг этой шестёрки.
Первое. Завистники. Завистники - это те
люди, с которыми я не хотел бы общаться,
не хотел бы иметь ничего общего и
общение с которыми я всячески и стараюсь
избегать. Это то качество, которое мне
сильно не нравится в людях. И знаете, в
основе зависти лежит не созидание, а
разрушение. Завистники они - это те
люди, которые не хотят, чтобы у меня
было как у них. Они больше хотят, чтобы
у других перестало это быть. Они больше
желают разрушения у других и появления у
себя. Поэтому изначально мне не нравится
намерение и посыл завистников.
Завистники - это ужасные люди, с
которыми лучше не общаться. И, вы
знаете, вообще зависть - это крайне
плохое чувство. Если вы ловите себя или
в себе такое чувство, постарайтесь его
максимально искоренить. Понятно? Может
быть, даже, а, с помощью психологов
понять причину, откуда она появилась, и
постарайтесь это ускоренить. Это
качество сильно тормозит ваше развитие и
не позволяет вам достигать ваших целей.
А если у вас этого качества нет, то я
вам очень сильно рекомендую избегать
таких людей и исключить из своей жизни
завистников. Вторая категория людей -
это лгуны. Это те люди, которые врут.
Есть, причём, люди, которые врут всегда
и постоянно. Я вообще людей делю на
такие три категории. Есть 20% людей,
которые не врут никогда ни при каких
обстоятельствах, даже в шутку. Есть 20%
людей, которые лгут постоянно всегда. И
когда в серьёзной обстановке, и в шутку,
и всегда, даже в тех случаях, когда нет
необходимости врать. И людей - это те
люди, которые ведут себя по
обстоятельствам. Если обстоятельства
позволяют, они могут чуть-чуть приврать.
Если обстоятельства не позволяют, они не
врут и являются честными людьми. К
сожалению, я не отношусь к то к тем
двадцати людям, которые никогда не врут.
Но, к счастью, я я не отношусь к тем 20%
людей, которые врут всегда. Но я ближе к
этой первой двадцатке, так как я охотник
и рыбак, у меня есть иногда вот этот
небольшая ложь в виде преувеличения, в
виде преувеличения своих трофеев, в виде
преувеличения своих заслуг. И это у меня
больше даже не ложь, а оно больше
хвостовство и тщеславие. Откровенно вам
признаюсь, это есть, и я с этим
постоянно борюсь. Это я просто как
отступление. Но вторая категория людей,
с которыми я стараюсь не общаться - это
вот эти 20% в основном, которые всегда
врут, даже когда в этом нет
необходимости. Такие люди реально могут
завести просто вашу жизнь, разрушить
полностью. Третья категория людей,
которых я избегаю и которые мне не
нравятся - это гордецы. Это те люди,
которые
у которых чрезмерно развито эго и
гордыня, которые пренебрежительно
относятся к другим людям, которые
сильно возвышают себя и ставят себя выше
других. И такие люди могут накликать
беду на вас и на вашу компанию. Если в
вашей компании такие сотрудники,
особенно руководители подразделений, то
это те люди, которые не воспринимают
ничего нового, а которые не впитывают
новых знаний, и они считают, что они всё
знают. Как правило, гордецы они и все
знайки, которые не принимают ничего
нового. Они консерваторы. Поэтому такие
люди ничего хорошего ни в вашей жизни не
принесут, ни в ваш бизнес, потому что
они не позволят, а, проникнуть ничему
новому. И они не позволят раскрыться
вашим талантам, потому что это люди
эгоцентричные, которые думают только о
себе, и всё, весь мир крутится вокруг их
эда. Четвёртая категория людей - это
негативщики и критиканы. Вот есть
определённая категория людей, которые
всё вот чтобы они не видели, они всё
негативт, вот всё критикуют. Когда ты
предлагаешь им какую-то возможность, они
видят только плохую сторону, они видят
только риски, они видят препятствия,
барьеры, они видят всё в тёмном свете.
Причём они эти барьеры и препятствия
преувеличивают, а вознаграждение и
удовольствие после достижения
преуменьшают. Они сразу же как бы
прогнозируют негативный путь и неудачу.
Они таким образом как бы каркают, что
ли, можно так сказать. Или критиканы.
Критика - это те люди, которые, а,
подавляют вообще творчество любое.
Поэтому с ними вообще нельзя общаться,
потому что они забивают ваше творческое
начало. При них даже неудобно что-то
креативить и и что-то предлагать. То
есть они своим присутствием уже нарушают
баланс и разрушают вас как личность, чем
что вам неудобно при них креативите
что-то предлагать. Вы знаете, что это
встретиться в штыки будет много негатива
и будет очень много критики. Поэтому
самый лучший способ - это не
переделывать их, а просто избегать
общения с такими людьми и убирать таких
людей из своей жизни. Пятая категория -
это нытики. Они всё время жалуются.
Жалуются на правительство, на
президента, на свою компанию, на
работодателя, на соседей, на
родственников, на мать, на отца, на
вселенную, на погоду. Они всё время ноют
и жалуются. Ноют и жалуются, ноют и
жалуются. И таких людей надо исключать
из своей жизни, потому что они меняют
восприятие, ваше восприятие этого мира.
И вот это нытё и и жалобы - это вещь
заразная, потому что ваша энергия и ваше
настроение, она тоже волнами двигается.
И если это попадёт в вашу низкую фазу
вашей энергии, то вы можете незаметно
сами скатиться в нытьё и жалобы. Поэтому
вместо нытиков и жалобщиков лучше иметь
отношения с позитивными людьми, которые
даже в плохом видет хорошее. Тогда,
когда у вас будет низкий уровень
энергии, вы не скатитесь, а в жалобы и
нытьё, а будете продолжать позитивно
смотреть на жизнь. И это, кстати,
быстрее восстановит вашу энергию и силы.
И это быстрее приведёт к вам к решению
проблем и восстановлению после
любых ошибок. И шестая категория, с
которыми я предпочитаю не общаться и
которых я стараюсь избегать, это
неудачники и не везунчики. Это не
очевидная такая вещь, но, вы знаете,
есть категория людей, которые почему-то
постоянно не их сопровождает неудачей. И
этому есть определённая причина. И очень
часто бывает так, что причина бывает в
каких-то их паттернах поведения либо в
какой-то их психологии. Но если вы
видите, что человек неудашлив и он не
везунщик, то просто знайте, что в этом
есть причины, и эта причина кроется в
нём самом. Просто вы ещё не распознали и
не увидели это. Благоразумно сторониться
таких людей и избегать таких людей. Ещё
очень важная такая вещь. А, конечно же,
не всё в этом мире мы можем, а,
объяснить, и наука это не может
объяснить. Но, вы знаете, неудачи и
невезение - вещь заразная. и неудачи, и
невезения, они ходят кучками. Говорят же
в народе: "Пришла беда, отворяй ворота!"
Или беда не приходит одна. Все беды и
несчастья, они как-то имеют свойство
кучками, а приходить. Поэтому шестая
категория людей, с которыми я
предпочитаю не иметь ничего общего и
стараюсь их обходить и не приближать к
себе, это неудачники и не везунщики.
Может возникнуть вопрос: а почему я
общаюсь с такими людьми? То есть, когда
вы посмотрите это видео и начнёте думать
о своём окружении, может выясниться
такая вещь любопытная, что вы общаетесь
с одной из категорий этих людей, а может
быть, даже с двумя категориями, а может
быть, со всеми, и это может быть очень
неприятным сюрпризом для вас. И тут
возникает вопрос: а почему вы общаетесь?
Почему вы продолжаете с ними общаться?
Это может быть причины э исторического
характера, когда это ваши родственники,
ваши друзья, ваши одноклассники, ну, те,
которые вы исторически, условно говоря,
с судьбой были связаны, и вы не можете
полностью прервать с ними связи и
отношения. Ну, как я сказал, надо
минимизировать. Но если это ваши друзья
и та среда, в которой вы общаетесь, то
есть вы общаетесь с ними добровольно,
вот тут надо подумать вот над чем это.
говорит только об одном, что скорее
всего
в вас есть одно из этих качеств, потому
что подобное тянется к подобному. Если
вы поймали себя на том, что в вашем
окружении есть люди из этих шести
категорий, то проанализируйте своё
поведение, свой характер, свои действия
и попытайтесь устранить эти свои
недостатки, потому что они сильно
тормозят вашу жизнь. Напишите в
комментариях, какие люди из этих шести
категорий есть в вашем окружении. Просто
мне любопытно знать, много ли в вашем
окружении таких людей. Ещё один вопрос,
который может возникнуть. А, да, я
подумал, да, у меня в моём кругу есть
одна из или несколько категорий тех
людей, а как вот перестать с ними
общаться? Я вам не рекомендую сразу же
прерывать с ними общение резко, но
первое, что вам нужно сделать, самим не
проявлять инициативу, связанную с
общением с ними. То есть сами их не
приглашайте навстречу, сами а не
заходите к ним в кабинет общаться и так
далее. Второе, старайтесь, когда а такие
люди проявляют инициативу на встречу с
вами и хотят с вами поговорить,
старайтесь всячески
откладывать. Знаете, это как в аэропорту
Дютифри. Кто знает, наверное,
подтвердить, что такфри, вернее,
покупайте вещи в магазине, а потом в
аэропорту вы хотите, чтобы вам, э, сдали
вернули налоги. Это называется таксри
при вылете из какого-то зарубежного
аэропорта. Так вот, государство
специально такие службы ставит в самый
дальний конец аэропорта, создавая
неудобство. Так вот, я рекомендую, чтобы
прекратить или уменьшить общение с
такими людьми. Создавайте потихоньку как
можно больше неудобств и препятствий и
барьеров для общения с ними. Делайте это
более технично, а не в лоб. То есть,
избавляясь от этих этих категорий людей,
вы должны чётко в голове держать одну
мысль. Эти все категории людей, они
негативные люди, люди с негативной
энергией. Поэтому отходите от них нужно
очень аккуратно, не создавая себе
врагов, потому что эти люди очень быстро
и легко могут прийти в разряд ваших
врагов. Я надеюсь, сегодня я вам дал
полезную информацию, и руководству с
этой информацией вы почистите свой круг
общения. Если вы это сделаете, то вы
очень скоро убедитесь, как начнёт
меняться ваша жизнь. И более того, она
не просто начнёт меняться сама по себе,
начнёт меняться ваши отношение к этой
жизни и начнут меняться ваши поведение,
ваши действия. Более того, начнёт даже
меняться ваш характер. Поэтому крайне
рекомендую избегать шесть категорий этих
ужасных типов людей, которые могут
разрушить как ваш бизнес, так и вашу
семейную и личную жизнь. Желаю вам
удачи. Будьте счастливы.